what you think of that case snoozefest
thought it was a snooze festival how
many snooze fest have you gone to now I
have been for a few years because
parking was so tough arguing or five
years ago sounds like snooze people are
sleeping in their cars you can't even
get into the parking lot people can't
wait to smooth a no need they don't
realize they're gonna be stayed at home
how we do it stay home here isn't at
home is free I'm gonna turn the heat on
every single case that I am a guest
bailiff for I want to grow and I want to
learn and that's what I did today we did
I did how did you grow I take that back
I learned I learned that that mother is
willing which I give guarantee the woman
the woman it's unclear whether he wanted
the products sounds a little like a
little pushy mom kind of scenario like
seems like she pushed a monomer he might
have done him to be nice he's out there
chasing a dream he wants to act he wants
to model he's got poses he has poses he
used all his rolling out po you don't
just pose like that unless you've posed
like that before right I'm glad at least
a few gigs he's had a few gigs and then
here he is he's got to be on set and
he's got acne all over his face if that
happens to me I'm not throwing those
products away I'm lighting them on fire
and I'm throwing them into a gully or
something is that oh yeah goalie yeah I
I feel like maybe there's no gullies
near where he lives but you never know
can you get Siri on your phone and say
where's the nearest gully I leave my
phone in the locker room every crisis
thank you to a hockey game I'd imagine
[Music]